源さんハイあのおにぎりで知っています
保人おにぎりー
名前だけ聞いてございますあー名前だけあのねおにぎりっていうのはお米をスプレー
握って
それを海苔でつつんでね三角とかマルとかって中に自分の好きな部を入れて食べると
いうものなんだけど
食べたいん
まあ食べたいです
basso 美貌的でおにぎりでございますその兄なんですけれども
街マター嘘噂が立っておりまして
30秒で食べれないっていう
ブービーきれない you do . info 牡丹ベルないんじゃないか r そ
ですとそう思ってたんです私
やったんですかああヌー
か
ビジターフェザーショップ b ライスサービスです今回ですね
コンビニのおにぎりが30秒で食べきれない説が浮上しておりますなんで今日はねまぁ
ちょっと軽くね
またいう元を聞けないね30秒でパクッと口もずっとを燃やす
でどっちでもいいでしょたぶんね2リザードリオちょっとアレなんで
陸奥じゃあこっちからいいんまずはわかめご飯かで行けます
普通に入れてから飲み込むまで30秒盛り込んだ時点のさっぶですと飲み込んで前の
30日および髪染めましたありがとうござん
b
スタート
あっキモッ
もう本当は法バージョンで行ってみようと思います
何かあったら俺の今は作戦でたくさん口に含んだロー
時間のせだから一番近くメディアアーツマッチまた黒しま
よしこいや
チェックが入っさん
2 h スター後の離職ええええええっ
10秒計がー
ていません
20秒経過
上り5秒
1 e
謎つますから本当に危ないカラー
できればやめておいてくださいやるとしても無人のまま飲み込まないようにして
くださいただ本当に飲み込むまでませんでした
急いでるタイプ